not dad not dad oh don't worry I'm app
heads for that target Europe well this
looks really nice love love the
decoration or read luck
[ __ ] [ __ ] a [ __ ] what did I do to her
writing shortly the ceremony is about to
begin
why would they have a certain ceremony
about a bird girls first period
that's cecal to leave soon Elizabeth
just lie down on the table and drink
this no let's go yes of course you can
that's right my fraps did killing the
framerate I don't know what's up with
that
nope well [ __ ] it looks like we'll have
to go here browse yeah we're going to
the left we're going to the right I
don't even know how to dance all night
breakdown park
what does everything need a [ __ ] key
Misaki no of course the Matthew key
don't work Misaki done diddly don't live
up to its name I say that's what I say I
said it didn't hear me jeez
what the [ __ ] alright well we will go we
will go hey yes here this is the right
way I know it because I said it yes
seems about right hello Oh another demon
pentagram love those
all right cool if I had a machine gun I
could just barricade myself and black
poem headshot I would be a sniper though
but what got damage with it
all right well this room is pretty
[ __ ] pointless
it's not even Oh it's 50% porn so I'll
take it
oh there's a boom-boom named Nisha my
god this is history
son of a J no well whatever okay huh
all right let's see what nope please
help [ __ ] you
who's there what Simon you how did you
get down here I haven't seen you since
you were cha I don't know father
what happened okay I can move that's
interesting Li's help me I'll help you
but first you have to tell me what
really happened to Adame tell me what
like I killed her
no no I wasn't necessarily stop saying
it was necessary
what are you talking about you murdered
your own daughter please please
understand they they made me do it I had
no other choice
[Music]
who made you do it the communion I I was
in too deep they they told me there's no
other way and why should I trust you
please there should be a saw in the lab
what No retrieve it for me and I tell
you the rest
no what hello
the lab key
whoa thick [ __ ] a man's man what's
going on in here
shut up shut up oh hello bucket thank
you you're a nice a where girls I had
now it never works now about scheisse
[ __ ] well I tried I tried and I failed
but that's ok as always I care to try
and fail that's what mama appears always
said but then she slapped me yep
now she knows I'm a don't call the blade
stasis Jake don't don't
okay you can go just kidding don't don't
who would you call anyway go I don't
even know ghostbusters
anyway what the [ __ ] it okay here we
found it I found it while talking say I
could do two things at once
aren't you jealous well it's the saw shy
said saw says now you are hello okay
well that's good you know with that but
here's a joke I'm bringing my share too
I think you like it but they're shut up
but paired you make me cry Shh here will
like you everyone will like shares
everyone like shares I never receive a
share as a present it's [ __ ] stupid
why would everyone ever ever do I give
me a [ __ ] chair polish it I say bull
[ __ ] but pears I could be your choice
shh shh don't speak it's better if you
don't
alright so I have to share
well [ __ ] my legs are shitty saw - I'm
grateful it's none of my bet she doesn't
want you mr. cherrick explained
everything what really happened to
Elizabeth Tommy
what did you hear this chart hi
I have evidence against the outing any
sentence what's going on here
your father know what I don't think that
guy's your father
oh my god what a plot twist
shut up Cheerios
don't listen to a [ __ ] it's kind of
throw you off oh my god I told you we
couldn't trust appears
I just like watching blood spill
you're crazy but here's my number
am i sacrifice my
pampers it's gonna be okay
[Music]
watch catch yeah jump scared old man
oh [ __ ] jebel dot got goddamnit
no I'm out of here [ __ ] ah I wanna rock
let me run woman okay look fine my fine
we're fine we're fine we're fine but
bike but fine
no thang what did you so ugly a what the
fog okay okay okay okay okay okay okay
now you get it you like to be naked but
they're not gay
stop stop this nonsense [ __ ]
why did you go where he was come in come
in yes gay people like this out
doc doc what Granick runnin runnin
runnin runnin runnin runnin runnin
runnin runnin runnin runnin runnin Oh
Hey Oh [ __ ] - Dodds sure do something
but the fog
[Applause]
machine gun is it safe
Jesus that guy is crazy shares saved my
life oh my god ah why do I sit I thought
I was gonna go in there why not leave
now we know the truth no I'm stuck I'm
serious
I can't open this door
hey fun well that did it [ __ ] way I
did it alright alright don't worry don't
wait don't worry
[Applause]
this is not what I wanted to go at all
oh nice ash
okay well where am I going then I'm so
lost
[Applause]
oh oh I'm going there now okay but don't
follow me okay [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] man
we're fine right five four five four
five four five we're fine
[Applause]
[Music]
[ __ ] all of you oh hey your penis is
really nice Jennifer you saved my life
I brought my family pears I love you
whatever oh no come on you got a [ __ ]
out now yeah little puss
come man come on crawl crawl mother
what the names in here oh okay I get it
huh
that's not possible nah
please why didn't he just take her and
run away thank you this is [ __ ]
creepy man
I won't let you do this she's my only
daughter just run away
the sugar dip here Elizabeth I want you
to have this necklace no it's for your
ceremony in a few dates I want you to
look nice manning right that ain't right
man and be able to leave soon Elizabeth
just lie down on the table and drink
this God done dead did they [ __ ]
right now he poisoned his doctor that is
sick man so now you realize really as I
found my way out of the mines I decided
I'd never looked back I had my edges I
guess yeah I wandered along the road for
almost a day before some kids
well that's nice through documentation
or letters I discovered my mother was
still alive living alone I don't like
this ambience I don't trust this man she
was surprised to see me and the stress
of old age was replaced with belief it
happens she took me to Elizabeth's gray
in a town not far from cousin villager
we stood there and say okay that's nice
all was well until until until at least
until the light burns god damnit they're
nightmare for the dreams they didn't
stop haltingly like before I just
couldn't seem to let go over my past it
was still something I had to do what
your name did I miss something breath
weeks past until one day in the morning
paper an article caught my eye body
found mutilated beyond identification
the location was near Crescent woman's
they were hungry
there were no Sakura oh I realized what
I had I don't want to go back I pushed
for the reopening of the mines and
cousin boards claiming there was still
rich with materials the newly reopened
mind attracted many workers and their
families desperate to make some money
well they consistent village populated
again no really that was quick
I started bringing the demons of
sacrifices really the end justifies the
means I realized that this was fun what
are you sick no it's not this was my
destiny
no it wasn't eventually sacrificing
became routine I started staying to
watch the beaches feed upon the victims
such elegance the way to the tether
fashion such beauty the blood flowed out
to the stream but they were satisfied
and oddly so was I
goddamnit
oh well that was obscurity for us that
was a cool story I felt the love to
silent a leash at some points but it was
still against sari and a fun a fun
custom story at least I really enjoyed
playing it it was a thrill it was very
like scary up to me that the right parts
I can feel on knowing to play a tiny
parts which is kind of hard to achieve I
think as I played a lot of custom
stories and there's at least one point
where I'm not really enjoying what the
[ __ ] I'm doing
but it was still really good all the way
through great voice acting and yeah a
good play what can I say
alright press I'm gonna go and play with
the kittens I mean I'm gonna go and do
something manly like a part of you know
I subscribe to come to read today and
I'll see you next episode of Alvin say
awesome
[Music]
yay doctor title screen
okay